this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
Richard Dasher among the
do it Stanford I direct the u.s. Asia
Technology Management Center and the
u.s. age of Technology Management Center
is producing a series of public lectures
and university seminars this autumn
about green technologies and
transportation recent developments from
Asia this is available for Stanford
University credit to Stanford students
under course number Electrical
Engineering 402a topics and
international technology management so
what we're trying to do with this series
is to capture a very important set of
developments transportation accounts for
about twenty eight percent of all of
india's energy in the United States and
in China it accounts for about twenty
percent of all energy consumption now
out of that energy consumption
transportation accounts for about sixty
percent of all of the petroleum use in
the world and this includes things from
liquid natural gas to gasoline and jet
fuel and diesel and so forth so in 2009
china surpassed the United States and
became the world's largest automobile
producer and market china had a hundred
seventy million automobiles on the road
at the end of 2009 and the country
predicts that there will be an
additional 220 million cars on the road
by 2020 so not surprisingly China's
share of co2 emissions has grown up has
grown drastically from 1973 when it
accounted for about five point seven
percent of the world's carbon dioxide
emissions to 2009 when it accounted for
twenty three point seven percent so the
issue of transportation needing to
become more green is widely understood
what we're going to look at in the
seminar series with distinguished
speakers from industries from government
organizations may be from another
University or two
is three major types of content the
first major area are the vehicles
themselves so we'll be talking about
electric automobiles will be talking
about electric buses will also be
talking about technologies to improve
the performance of ships and airplanes
will be talking about efficiency through
the use of new materials will be talking
about efficiency through new powertrain
technologies and also through new
approaches to using IT so that's the
first major sector second major sector
in this will be fuels and energy storage
we have to look at the battery
technologies as well as the vehicles in
which the batteries are being placed and
finally many people think only of
electric vehicles when they think about
green technologies and transportation
but it's very important to consider the
total system to look at the entire kind
of logistical system all around air
transport is a very useful way to find
efficiencies on the ground that can
reduce the energy footprint of the whole
industry also intelligent transportation
systems are a major feature of new green
technologies and transportation we're
talking about Road sensors sensors and
vehicles in advanced computing that
might be able to reduce the total number
of hours or number of miles that a
transportation network has to bear in
fact the whole system concept really
includes just changing the way that
people behave from using their own cars
to adopting public transportation we're
focusing in this series on what's going
on in Asia that's probably less heard
about than what's happening in the US or
in Europe and yet there are initiatives
in every major Asian economy to improve
the greenness of transportation for
example China by 2020 plans to increase
its hybrid and electric vehicle
production
fifteen percent of all of the
automobiles produced it's going to
double its long distance high-speed rail
network and in the Beijing area it's
going to increase the line distance of
its metro rail system to six hundred
sixty kilometers by 2015 and over a
thousand kilometers by 2020 South Korea
has a plan to increase the share of its
total transportation by rail to fifteen
percent in 2010 it was eight point seven
percent Malaysia is already in phase 2
of an electric vehicle roadmap in which
is running pilot projects with proton
and meets abhi she and Nissan Motors so
we have a number of different issues
that we need to deal with in this series
for this particular session right now I
just want to give you a few of the
highlights that are coming up on October
the 4th our first session in the series
I'll be giving a more in-depth overview
of what's going on on October 11 we have
dr. Osama anoeta who is the Silicon
Valley representative of a Japanese
government organization the new energy
and industrial technology development
organization he's going to be talking
about their investments in green
transportation especially areas such as
integrating electric vehicles to the
grid on October 18 we have professor
keto Shimizu who is the CEO of a company
called sim drive a Japanese startup
company that has a new in wheel electric
motor that not only can be used for new
electric vehicles but even could convert
older gasoline-powered cars to
electricity on october 25th sandra it
cough who is a vice president of the
very large chinese firm byd will be
talking about batteries for electric
vehicles byd is the second largest
battery producer in China on November
first mr. Toshi Yuki Kondo who is this
Oh of Toure composites America will be
talking about their carbon fiber
materials that are now in the newest
aircraft like the Boeing 787 and what
kind of prospects these materials have
in the automotive industry so we'll also
have some sessions further on in the
series about emissions scrubbing we're
expecting to have a panel discussion on
maritime transportation we're trying to
engage a speaker on air transportation
systems and on the role of IT
convergence in green transportation the
series will continue through December
the six it's open to the public if you
can be here in person we always put out
some refreshments at the end of the
session and are happy to enjoy
face-to-face networking but we are very
happy if you can watch us on youtube or
if you're a stanford student if you can
watch us through SCPD and we look
forward to having you as part of the
series thank you very much
you